djebbour qui est contre la science et le
vite
la séance est levée passé on se devait
[Musique]
bonjour je suis grégory besson
eurodéputés la république en marche de
l'aube de la première circonscription je
suis aussi rapporteur du projet de loi
sur les néonicotinoïdes et je suis chez
alain carré qui est producteurs de
betteraves dans l'aube grégory besson
moreau est en charge d'un des textes les
plus controversés de la rentrée le
retour des néonicotinoïdes dans les
champs de betteraves un pesticide
redoutable pour l'environnement surnommé
le tueur d'abeilles
monsieur le député je vous invite à
avancer dans leurs champs de betteraves
rage aussi bien passer pour un tueur
d'abeilles c'est un rôle ingrat et
pourtant grégory besson moreau
l'assument car sa circonscription est un
territoire de betteraves
or cette année il y a un problème les
cultures sont malades
les chants d'alain carré ont pris une
teinte jaune privé de néonicotinoïdes
ces betteraves sont victimes d'un
pucerons porteur d'une maladie
il montre aux députés l'étendue des
dégâts donc voilà j'ai arraché des
betteraves des avec de la jaunisse par
rapport à des betteraves qui sont saines
d'accord alors généralement une
betterave qu'à la jaunisse emma les
feuilles sont joués on voit bien que les
feuilles sont viables voilà son jaune
cassante par rapport à une métrage qui
n'est pas touché donc les feuilles sont
beaucoup plus larges et puis paca sens
c'est et ensuite est la conséquence
directe à ses tubercules les racines
y'a pas photo la différence tout de
suite ça bah oui voilà entre des
betteraves atteindre de la jaunisse et
des betteraves scène c'est entre 30 à 40
% de perte de rendement un agriculteur
ne va pas replanter une deuxième année
pour refaire une perte
donc c'est pour cela qu'on demande la
dérogation sauver les abeilles ou la
filière betterave privilégié l'écologie
ou l'économie reg ory besson moreau n'a
pas hésité longtemps
il est du côté des agriculteurs de sa
circonscription mais à certaines
conditions
la dérogation sera pour trois ans pas
plus le temps de trouver une alternative
ce projet doit c'est pas un chèque en
blanc non plus non et je sais que c'est
pas de la faute des agriculteurs je
pense que la filière doit aussi
travailler sur elle-même on a eu du
temps pour arrêter les néonicotinoïdes
peut-être qu'il ya eu un manque de
travail de la part de la filière en
règle générale dire qu'on n'a rien fait
je suis pas d'accord nous chercheurs
on va recherche de variétés déjà
tolérante
la jaunisse ça fait déjà plusieurs
années
il nous manque encore 3 ans minimum pour
arriver à un stade où on peut avoir une
betterave qui est vraiment tolérantes à
la jaunisse cette année quand les
pucerons sont arrivés les seuls
traitements autorisés n'ont pas
fonctionné photos à l'appui
alain carré montre aux députés les
ravages causés par ce pucerons il est
convaincu que les néonicotinoïdes ne
sont pas si mauvais qu'on le dit il a
d'ailleurs préparé un atelier pratique
avec des graines de betteraves enrobé de
produits cellex-c
elles sont enrobés et là je vous ai
décortiqué l'enrobage pour vous montrer
ce que c'est qu'une graine de betteraves
l'idée de l'enrobage et de mettre
insecticides autour de cette graine donc
vous le voyez ici
ouais donc ces deux c'est un pelliculage
d'argile qui entoure ensuite on met une
fine couche de nero cottineau ide et
ensuite le pelliculage pour emprisonner
le tout il n'ya pas de dispersion de
produits
voilà et ensuite la betterave avait
germé et avec ses petites radicelles à
va commencer déjà à prendre le produit
gentiment et ainsi de la protéger c'est
le bien-être végétales comme on peut
parler du bien-être animal
quand on vous entend parler des
néonicotinoïdes comme vous le faites
pour les interdits passé c'est juste une
solution miracle
oui il ya quand même un travail un
problème pour l'environnement et va sur
la betterave
non sincèrement non
des néonicotinoïdes sans danger pour
l'environnement alain carré n'est pas le
seul dans la circonscription à vouloir y
croire
ici la betterave fait vivre beaucoup de
monde au delà des champs il y à une
industrie voici la sucrerie distillerie
d'arcis sur aube
c'est la plus importante de france
d'habitude à cette époque
lusine tourne à plein régime mais
aujourd'hui elle est vide
pas une betterave très peu d'ouvriers la
jaunisse est passée par là on a fait le
choix de décaler le démarrage de
campagne pour laisser les betteraves un
petit peu plus long dans le champ et
espérer maximiser un peu plus fort
rendement le point d'équilibré
aujourd'hui le temps de fonctionnement
qui fait que la sucrerie est rentable
c'est sait combien de jours en moyenne
120 jours son vainqueur c'est la bonne
valeur et là on va tomber en dessous de
100 jours peut-être même à 90 jours de
campagne
on peut tenir là parce que quand on a
serré aussi allés tous les deux jours
mais c'est pas tenable plus de deux ans
le groupe a déjà fermé deux sucreries en
france l'an dernier c'est toute la
filière qui souffre et réclame cette
dérogation car ailleurs en europe
certains ne s'embarrasse pas avec les
questions environnementales des 17 pays
qui produit de la betterave en deux à
l'époque
quatorze pays utilisent la dérogation
qui leur permet à un pays à utiliser des
vo du petit oeil dans leur chambre et
nous la france comme les producteurs de
cuivre
d'après jean ce projet de loi si je
résume c'est une première étape est la
seconde étape c'est une étape européenne
essaie de régler
regardez ce problème d'avancé ce n'est
qu'un problème au niveau européen
l'enjeu est clair sauver une filière qui
représente 46 mille emplois en france
la pression est lourde elle va se
ressentir lors de ce débat organisé par
grigori bessonneau on est réuni ce soir
c'est pas pour m'écouter
c'est surtout pour vous écouter dans
tête de ce projet de loi l'idée du
député c'est de faire dialoguer deux
mondes qui ne se parle pas d'un côté les
acteurs de la filière venus en nombre
de l'autre les écologistes ils ne sont
que quelques-uns regroupés dans un coin
et ils vont avoir du mal à se faire
entendre
si divers prochain est un hiver froid le
problème de la jaunisse ne se reproduira
pas donc la réponse que vous apportez là
me semble très excessifs par rapport à
un phénomène qui est conjoncturelle moi
je vous propose que vous soyez
agriculteurs et puis vous démontriez
comment il faut faire
vous êtes prêts à tuer l'agriculteur
français nous on nous interdit tout par
contre on laisse tout rentre et
d'ailleurs et on le fait manger à nos
citoyens français
alors là je supporte pas c'est passé un
dialogue de sourds
et cela ne va pas s'arranger avec cet
apiculteur qui prend la parole
son cv est impressionnant j'aurais tout
ceci philippe lecomte apiculteurs
professionnels en champagne président du
réseau de l'université pour les abeilles
cofondateur de l'institut technique
apicole fondateur de symbiose pour des
paysages de nos diversités et dix
présidences figuré
l'apiculteur un beau militer pour la
biodiversité
il est venu défendre les néonicotinoïdes
il se pose clairement en expert depuis
2018 pour n'utilise plus les
néonicotinoïdes on utilise massivement
les pyréthroïdes de synthèse et quand on
fait des analyses dans les matrices à
picot avait en particulier dans les sirh
on retrouve les prêts trop id alors que
donc il y avait les néonicotinoïdes ont
retrouvé pas de l'eau nicotine aux ide
ce qui veut dire perd même que du point
de vue et d'appui aux diversités on peut
se poser quand même la question savoir
si les néonicotinoïdes alors là je vais
faire hérétiques
c'est pas un avantage pour la filière
apicole même dans cette salle le
discours surprend mais les agriculteurs
vont vite en faire leur miel
merci responsables au niveau de culture
parce que vous avez ramené comme on dit
l'église au milieu du village
les écologistes vont quand même faire
une dernière tentative
le débat l'impression que tout va bien
que les néo nicotine sont formidables
non toutes les études européennes toutes
les études scientifiques sont quasiment
est quasiment un consensus sur la
dangerosité de ces molécules
il ya deux apiculteurs qui viennent de
s'exprimer et qui disent qu'avec une ou
deux des côtes et un oeil sur betteraves
il n'y a pas de problème pour moi ça
vaut au moins 15 20 ou 50 et [__]
c'est des praticiens le discours de
l'apiculteur a clairement pesé dans le
débat à l'assemblée
un député a déjà eu à faire à cet homme
matthieu orphelin et contre les
pesticides
il s'est penché sur le profil de
l'apiculteur philippe lecomte et ce
qu'il a découvert et d'assez surprenant
ce monsieur le comte se présente comme
président du réseau biodiversité pour
les abeilles
hélas en creusant mais très rapidement
en allant sur le site de ce réseau on
voit qu'en fait bon nombre d actions de
ce réseau sont financés par des
fabricants pesticides notamment basf
est-ce que effectivement le fait que ce
monsieur représente un institut dont les
actions sont financées par des
fabricants de pesticides
est ce que tout ça était bien clairement
expliqué à l'ensemble des personnes qui
ont assisté à ce débat parce que sinon
on est sur un débat un peu tronqué
derrière l'apiculteur se cachait-il un
lobbyiste et que faisait t-il dans un
débat organisé par le rapporteur du
projet de loi
gregory b son bourreau plaide
l'ignorance qu'une personne vienne dans
une réunion publique que j'organise et
que cette personne ne me dise pas qu'au
final il a au sein de son association
une un industriel des produits
phytopharmaceutiques qui est qui
peut-être finance cette association à
titre personnel je vous le dis ça me
dérange
je n'étais pas au courant et si jamais
on m'avait donné cette information là je
vous assurer que je leur ai demandé de
retirer sa parole peut-être ou de la
conserver en tant que lobbyiste
mais dans cette réunion il y avait le
représentant du syndicat apicole de
l'aube qui lui étaient présents bon
les gens prennent pas la parole que ce
soit et je vous dise le député renvoie
la balle dans le camp des apiculteurs
fermez le ban grégory besson moreau
c'est que le débat sera autrement plus
musclée dans l'hémicycle les adversaires
des néonicotinoïdes compte bien s'y
faire entendre et ils ont des arguments
alou nous oui ou non autorisée
l'empoisonnement intentionnelle des
terres de france désormais il suffira de
mettre en avant une difficulté
économique pour avoir la peau d'une
avancée environnemental nous n'héritons
pas de la terre de nos ancêtres nous
l'empruntons à nos enfants et moi j'ai
envie de laisser à mes enfants une
tercel le sud ce qui vient de la
betterave française doit pas être
exempts de pesticides
il ne doit pas contribué à empoisonner
l'eau il ne doit pas contribué à
empoisonner le sucre que nous allons
manger les arrivées vôtre monsieur le
président mélenchon vos propos d'estrade
ne feront jamais poussé une betterave de
notre pays jamais c'est votre
responsabilité de vouloir aujourd'hui
faire tomber cette filière mais ça ne
sera pas notre responsabilité
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 1
127 exprimer
471 majorité 236 pour 313 contre 158
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
la loi est largement adopté mais il a
fallu les voix de la droite
jamais la majorité ne s'est autant
divisée avec 32 votes contre et 36
abstentions au sein du groupe en marche
des gens ont voté pour et d'autres ont
voté contre ou se sont abstenus
peut-être que ce sont des parlementaires
élus de territoire ultra urbain et qui
n'ont pas conscience
de la réalité de nos territoires ruraux
pour moi ce texte est la fin des neuf
vies quotidiennes mais l'histoire n'est
pas finie
devant l'assemblée des militants
écologistes lance la bataille de
l'opinion sur les mets haut niveau tenue
encore une fois le gouvernement agissent
main dans la main avec le lobby des
belles foules c'est surtout sur les
réseaux sociaux que s'organise la
contestation les députés ils sont
épinglés selon leur vote sans surprise
le visage de grégory besson moreau y
figure en bonne place
[Musique]